earlier this month the u.s ambassador to
the united nations linda thomas
greenfield
visited the last border crossing
bringing humanitarian aid from turkey
into syria
babal hawa is according to the un a
lifeline for 2.4 million people
but its fate now hangs in the balance in
2014 the un security council
authorized four border crossings but the
others didn't stay open after russia and
china used their veto power
two council members have now put forward
a draft resolution
which would again allow two crossing
points so what nori and ireland did was
without looking at anything other than
the needs
we proposed a renewal and an expansion
of the mandate
but at a news conference the russian
ambassador made it pretty clear
he'd be prepared to use his veto to stop
a second border point
we told him in the very beginning that
what we hear from our colleagues about
reopening the closed cross-border points
is really a non-stutter
we are discussing uh the one that is
remaining
are you saying you currently do not see
a need for even a single
border crossing i will not give you any
definite
definitive answer at this time i will
only say that we are continuing we
continue consulting on that issue
germany's outgoing un ambassador who led
negotiations on the issue when his
country was on the security council
told al jazeera other countries must
stand strong
we cannot allow and agree to a solution
where all of a sudden humanitarian aid
is cut for
you know some russian ambition to
support the regime of assad the issue
was discussed earlier this month between
president putin and president biden
and has been the subject of recent talks
between the russian and turkish foreign
ministers
so will the last border crossing into
syria close
the un security council is due to vote
before the 10th of july deadline
james bayes al jazeera at the united
nations